arrête
d'enregistrer ce genre de plan ouais
ouais
et si on monte plus haut, ça devient encore plus
flou je pense que oui, d'habitude, tu
veux
essayer, finissons le plan ouais, comment ça
va finir, je ne suis pas sûr de ce qui
va se passer ici  euh,
nous roulons depuis environ une minute
ouais
essayons juste ouais et bien nous pourrions aussi bien
avoir un peu de temps pour tuer qu'est-ce qu'on
essaie d'essayer de continuer à grimper continuer à
grimper ouais
ouais ouais hélicoptère L'ombre soit quelque part
dans le plan mais à  au moins, ils ont tiré, ils
ont tiré ici
de toute façon, vous pouvez l'obtenir si vous mettez un
peu plus de ciel, ciel vraiment brumeux oh ouais,
c'est totalement brumeux
ouais, j'ai besoin du polariseur pour m'en débarrasser, donc ça a l'
air un peu plus joli
là-bas
et si nous aimons un  180
pan prends les sketchs
ouais à droite à droite ouais ouais
45° à droite ou quelque chose comme ça je ne suis pas
sûr juste comme tu te tournes un peu
pour montrer l'immensité de l'
endroit clair clair clair clair ouais de
l'autre côté plus ouais  nous allons continuer à
venir
ouais, débarrassons-nous du clair et ensuite nous
pourrons recommencer le tir, alors, je peux
à peine voir, ok, est-ce que ça peut s'arrêter ouais à peu près
là, ok ouais, mais ensuite arrête-le pour que ça
fasse un autre
point
de rouler sur ce petit lac en dessous
nous et si je contourne vers la droite je
pourrais continuer à tourner vers la droite je
pense qu'on a choisi un endroit où il y a
trop de vert on est sur le rouge ça AIT
r
c'est
sympa arriver jusqu'à un petit bout d'
horizon là-dessus
toi  tu veux le transformer
à nouveau en soleil toi non non non non non non je ne verrai
rien ok eh bien euh descendons c'est
plus agréable d'en bas tu veux faire demi-tour
va à gauche en descendant puis on en
prendra un autre  tu pourras voir où
nous
allons si tu veux, il y a
un joli reflet sur ce
lac à 1h00 ouais, je vois que hé viens
beaucoup, arrête-toi
là,
euh arrête
d'enregistrer, ils roulent
encore,
il y a trop d'Evergreen ici, d'accord
peut-être  nous devions longer la
pente de la crête un peu à gauche, peut-être
pourrions-nous